this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm going to talk today run through
fairly quickly a whole bunch of
different directions the introductions
that I've investigated numerous angles
and so you're going to see a little bit
of a lot of different angles in this
talk so broccoli production in the
northeast of course I'm betraying my
California upbringing and pursuing this
topic at all but it turns out to be a
really interesting one with a lot of
potential in various different
directions so why would one care about
broccoli production in the Northeast so
we've got a number of different things
happening right now it kind of makes
this a compelling thing to pursue so
think you're all aware that locally
grown is a big deal everybody's talking
about locally grown produce as being
something attractive and that is showing
up in the marketplace as the
supermarkets and wholesalers are
starting to think about how can I get
local product into my store where can I
source it we can i buy it from we've
despite the lower diesel prices this
year for the past several years diesel
has been very expensive that's made
transportation from California very
expensive in fact the wholesale price of
broccoli and much other produce on the
East Coast half of that cost is the
transportation in half of it is the cost
that was paid in California that cost
does not come down with the diesel
process by the way it's still the same
high price so that's a barrier that
provides an opportunity to make money
for growers we're looking at reducing
the carbon footprint so shipping 10,000
pounds of broccoli and 10,000 pounds of
ice across the country as a substantial
footprint not only with the diesel but
the ice we can reduce that our vegetable
growers value diversification on their
farms value diversification on what
they're selling so both in the rotation
in economically diversification
and also is we've noticed with the
shortage of water in California this
year that having our production
diversified around the country can help
provide we're calling it food security
for the united states that we don't fall
short of crops that we really like
during periods when the one location
that it's grown something's happening
there that prevents us from getting it
so there's a number of angles to why we
would want to be looking at broccoli in
the Northeast right now why broccoli
people love broccoli who ate broccoli in
the last month yeah how about the last
week we've probably got some vegetables
look at that yeah so everybody eats
broccoli just about right it's a very
very popular crop and so this this chart
shows how the broccoli consumption per
capita has been going up of course
populations going up to the interesting
thing to me is down here at nineteen
seventy were about half a pound per
person a year that's not very much it
was an Italian specialty vegetable
pretty much in the 1960s it really only
became sort of something everybody ate
relatively recently and so there there's
a big upside for kale by the way it's a
half now after the burst in the last few
years it's gone from a quarter to a half
so it's really gone way up but you can
you can imagine the trajectory over the
next several years so there's only
upside potential so where do we grow
broccoli now well we grow it in
California of course is the answer so
this shows you that the big numbers are
how many acres of production there are
in each part so you see on the coast and
the summer in the desert in the
wintertime and a little smattering on
the East Coast and when you get to the
very northern most County where it's
good and cold there's a little patch
there a little winter production down
there but really it's a little
smattering and in fact I think we have
worked with each of the farm
that represents a dot unis map so
there's there's potential for increasing
that on the on the East Coast so why
can't we do that simply well first of
all the varieties that exist are poorly
adapted to our Eastern growing
conditions temperature water humidity
are and variability and all of the above
are really big challenges and so what's
been done to date is to raise broccoli
where the conditions are optimal for it
and that has worked but its demand goes
up we need to find more places the other
significant obstacle is that for any one
location we have a relatively short
harvest season so here would basically
be September right now you can grow
broccoli just fine if you harvest in
September the problem is that your
customers need broccoli 12 months out of
the year and they're not going to
abandon their reliable supplier for a
month to take your stuff that's the
growers dilemma so supplying year-round
turns out to be a very important element
of getting into the market and because
of that situation the distribution
network for growers throughout the East
is not really set up to handle a product
with a fresh market product with this
volume so just getting it from the
producers to the stores the very common
question from farmers I can grow it just
fine but who do I sell it to very common
question from retail produce buyers we
really want local broccoli but we can't
find anybody to raise it for us so this
seems like a dilemma that can be
overcome and it turns out this
distribution network is the problem so
where do we start well of course start
with breeding and improving the crop
because that's what we're really good at
and I'll talk in more detail about that
but breeding a better crop doesn't help
unless
farmers can buy the seed of it right
that's where the rubber meets the road
you can buy the scene if there's only
6,000 acres of broccoli in the East the
seed companies don't care they're not
going to spend money on developing
varieties marketing them releasing them
raising seed and selling those seed if
there's only a few growers so they
haven't been motivated to do anything at
all that's been a big obstacle so we've
tried to put together a project where we
can tempt them with the promise of
having a lot more acreage in the east so
it's worth their while and so this
promise of volume markets has developed
a promise of potentially having a lot
more Eastern growers more seed sales and
seed company interest and so just to
show you what the what the problem looks
like with warm nights not enough
chilling hours to put it roughly for
those of you taken plant physiology and
recognize that system so the flower buds
need cool temperatures to decide to
develop and obviously that didn't happen
at the right time in this one and so you
have some very teeny tiny floral
primordia there and some big flower buds
there that managed to squeak through
while it was still cool so that's what a
Western adapted variety looks like here
in the summertime this is a variety that
was bred for growing in warmer summer
conditions probably nobody would buy
this unless it was a friend who was
selling it to you me and this is pac-man
this is the variety that Eastern
broccoli production was based on for
about 20 years until maybe five or ten
years ago it still looks pretty rough
you can sell that in some markets but
certainly not in the supermarket trade
or the restaurant
trade so we need to have varieties that
look better than that so that's our the
physiological goal and the breeding goal
of the project so I runs really quickly
some of the physiology we did a number
of years ago because in case you've
forgotten or not yet aware because we're
going to be picking up on on this soon
so in development you have vegetative
meristem you recognize a little dome on
top there at a certain point the
flowering reproductive transition comes
along and so now you have a reproductive
meristem you can tell the difference the
main difference is this one's about
twice as big and there's a little flat
spot right there where it's starting to
develop a reproductive meristem here
little worlds of reproductive meristems
are being produced so each of the new
knobs is another reproductive meristem
and it gets bigger little bract coming
up at the base of some of the world's
and then on the rightmost figure you see
that there's a little ring around the
top of some of these those are now
floral primordial those little things
that the edges are Seabolt primordial so
they're starting to differentiate into
flowers which means they're not making
more meristems this just keeps going and
going so if it doesn't get enough
chilling hours during this period that's
when the transition to these low floral
meristems doesn't quite happen so this
is an inflorescence meristem looks like
cauliflower it's green but it looks like
cauliflower right this is the floral
primordial just to show you you can get
a good sized head consisting of nothing
but floral primordia arrested in
development the inset shows them a
little bit bigger and there's the gone
all the way to flower buds so you may
ask what's the genetic difference
between these because you know if we had
the gene we could solve it well all
three of those pictures are taken from
exactly the same genotype it's an f1
hybrid commercial green cauliflower
variety called green harmony widely
raised in Asia
it's an f1 hybrid they're all the same
the difference is the temperature so
it's gene expression is very important
what triggers gene expression after a
certain number of chilling hours are
accumulated so we'll take a quick look
at that so leafy is a gene that usually
if it turns on that's when you start
getting the floral differentiation in
here you can see a vegetative meristem
so the white speckles are where the gene
is being expressed so it's low in the
vegetative one starts to get higher
right in the outside surface of those
reproductive meristems and then when it
goes to flower buds it actually looks a
little bit lower which it stays high at
that point in arabidopsis it's a little
different so Denise to close a graduate
student here who looked at a whole set
of candidate genes that we believed from
a rabid opsys work would tell us where
the level of control was and we found
many genes that didn't do anything
interesting at all even though they
expected them to but there were a couple
so leafy when the transition from the
floral primordia to the flowers the
leafy drops off and when you have the
earlier transition we see that a petal
of one which is the petal designating
gene turns on so we have a couple of
transition so the question is what leads
up to that and so we compared as
development proceeds or the expression
levels of so we see leafy stops at this
one and ap-1 turns off there another one
called fruitful that was doing some
interesting things so to go to the next
step we're asking what regulates these
but when you compare broccoli with
what's going on in a rabid opsys we were
not encouraged to say well it happens
this way in a rabid dog
so therefore it must be happening the
same Lane broccoli they're just not
being expressed at the same stages and
it's a very complex network that leads
up to that and we ended up having a very
large number of candidate genes to try
to pursue a candidate gene approach so
that effort more or less stopped at that
point and that given the situation that
next step is really to pick it up at the
genomics level where you can look at all
of the genes you don't have to know in
advance and look at what that variation
is so that is a direction that sack
stencil will be pursuing here if you
went to grad review saw some of the
populations that he has available to
them to begin that so that will be
continuing onward but then we come to
the Eastern broccoli project which
funded no molecular work whatsoever but
many other things so this is a project
that was funded by the specialty crops
research initiative and it had a goal of
having year-round broccoli production of
equality that consumers want and so here
are sort of the harvest season starting
in Maine New York going south we got the
mountains of Kenneth Tennessee Kentucky
and Virginia South Carolina North
Carolina and then south Georgia and
Florida are sort of the different
production areas we're looking at and
the harvest season in each of those and
one of the things you can see is that
there is gaps even when we've got all
the production areas going there are
still gaps in the production season and
so the goal is to expand each of those
production seasons by increasing the
environmental adept adaptation of the
broccoli so that we can go wider and
have them overlap a little bit
so to realize the operative well the
Opera
and just to find the year-round
production we need not only the
varieties that have the right traits we
need that really wide adaptability so
that's a trait of sorts but it's really
a fundamental behavior of the plant we
need to get the varieties released the
seed companies need to be producing the
seed selling the seeds of them we need a
grower base that can expand so people
are expert at growing vegetables but not
currently doing broccoli how can they
start doing broccoli where does that
make sense for them and looking at the
supply so that we're having enough
broccoli coming on the market to meet
the demand but not so much that it
depresses the price and finding that
balance is actually not only challenging
but very location specific you can tank
the price in one market and have a
shortage in another one just a few
hundred miles away and then finally make
sure that the the product that's raised
in the east is valued by the consumers
and by the really the produce managers
are real roadblock in this one so we set
up a set of six objectives in the
project to try to hit all of those and
I'll talk a little bit about most of
them and so you may not even be able to
read that but this is some of the team
that was working together and so we had
a breeding group nutritional quality we
don't want to have the broccoli be less
healthy that would be rude the big
regional trial system in many locations
you're looking at economics both
national market systems and consumer
decision making we have a team from the
seed companies who are responsible for
commercialization a number of different
farms an extension team to make sure
that the growers had
priate guidance and then a bunch of
distribution and retail it turns out
it's it's not like this one big flow of
broccoli there's hundreds of different
markets all with their own expectations
so we try to represent a lot of those
and so a lot of integration with
industry in this project so looking at
the breeding element of it so we want to
improve the public sector germ plasm the
in the public sector there's a lot of
opportunity to make improvements that
don't make sense for the companies
especially bringing in more unusual
traits or starting with material that's
a little bit more odd than commercial
material we also want to discover the
best seed company germ plasm they've got
lots of packets of seeds stashed away
that didn't have enough market potential
before but maybe it does now let's find
it I want to combine the excellent
traits that are in the commercial germ
plasm with the new traits that would
come out of a public program we want to
understand the quantitative genetics of
the traits these are difficult traits in
understanding how they behave and
interact is important for making
progress nicking trials for hybrid
production not all couples are made in
heaven when it comes to broccoli so some
of them are very productive of seed some
are not if your seed company seeds are
your product so if you have a hybrid
that you want to sell on the plant it
just doesn't make a lot of seeds well
that's that's low productivity that's a
really big problem so it turns out that
the hybrids you see on the market are
from very fecund parental pairs so we
have three public programs so Griff's is
one of them here at Cornell
mark Farnham with a RS at Charleston
South Carolina and Jim Meyers at Oregon
State who's been reading for really the
processing industry as well as for
organic production so we wanted to bring
that in and then three private programs
the seed companies Jo Syngenta and
semanas were the ones who elected to
join us and is the person trying to get
all these people to talk to each other
in common language we find that each of
the breeding programs as a very distinct
way of going about things different
populations different goals so one of
the techniques was to try to encourage
them to compete a little bit with one
another so we have a regional trial
program so trying to make sure that
everybody feels the competitive urge to
have the best material in the regional
trial that proved helpful but then at
the same time we want them to
collaborate with each other to generate
cross program results there even better
and then we really want to get the
public material licensed so that crows
can get it licensing is is how it's done
these days but having the public
material then go to a seed company in
one of many forms and become available
and provide revenue to keep these
breeding programs going so there are the
breeders I mentioned them so here that
traits that the new varieties mean so
you notice it's a long list for starters
I'll only mention briefly we need the
stability across environments wide
adaptation because in any given location
you're going to have a lot of variation
in the weather and you don't know how to
predict it if you remember 365 days ago
what kind of jacket were you wearing and
what are you wearing today that's normal
variation
we need the uniform bead so that's
really genetically a chiller requirement
we need a good dome on it that's just so
the rain falls off that's all all you
need that for but you can have a
relatively flat head in California it
doesn't matter we need one that sheds
rain so it doesn't brought I want to
make sure it has all the ingredients
that make it healthy the market likes
really small flower buds right now but
really small flower buds are difficult
to hide uneven flower buds behind the
big ones hides stuff a lot better so how
much do you need that it needs to look
really green because people buy broccoli
because it's healthy green is healthier
right everybody works that way in their
head and this turns out to be not just
chlorophyll content but wax structure on
the surface what color anthocyanins so
there's a lot that goes into the green
so all of these are complex traits
there's not a single gene trait in the
bunch so figuring out how to pile all
these together is no small matter and to
really address the the first one in
particular we've set up a system of
regional trials where we are testing the
material very different location so we
want to identify the wide adaptation to
the east we want to collect a data set
where we can start to understand the
genetic control of some of these traits
there's huge environmental effects on
essentially all of them and there's a
substantial genotype by environments
interaction so to figure out anything at
all you need massive data sets
and particularly want to understand the
variation in nutritional quality because
that's that's the unit featured people
like we do see quite a lot of
environmental variation you see the
benefit a broccoli it's being sold as a
glue carafe and an enhanced broccoli
type and they don't tell you what
concentration it is because it varies
quite a lot with the growing conditions
they say it contains four times as much
as normal broccoli and that's entirely
true if you grow a regular variety and
Ben afford to next to each other the
benefit a generally runs about four
times as high but how much the absolute
number depends on the environment so
we've got a lot of variation there we're
trying to identify where different germ
plasm has complimentary traits so you
get one with a great dome and one that's
really green but you're not getting any
that have both for instance and and we
want the companies to buy and license
the public sector material so the these
regional trials they were set up in
three phases the first one we allow lots
and lots of entries we're essentially
calling at that stage we've got five
locations to plantings at each location
so lots of observations on those but not
a huge investment in them so that's an
effective culling step and that's where
we can attract there anything a breeder
things might look interesting it doesn't
have to win it just needs a chance to
win then we have a much more elaborate
stability trial here we have five
plantings at four locations but that way
we try many different times during the
season and really get a sense of how it
behaves we get vast variation in what
happens we try to hit a stressful time
and a non stressful time and sometimes
Nature cooperates this is also where we
look at the nutritional studies and
finally we go to looking at commercial
yields where we're on grower farms
seeing how they they actually behave
what kind of yield are they are they
going to make money
you know that how much does it cost to
harvest them you have to go in three
times or seven times that makes a big
difference we spent a lot of time
standardizing across locations so we had
both diagrams for how to score different
things we've got together and made sure
everybody sat in the same room and
looked at broccoli heads oh is this is
34 green or a 44 green talked about that
for a long time to make sure that
everybody was scoring the same way at
each location because we're trying to
compare numbers across locations so
having that be standardized was really
important so some of the dust that comes
out of it just a little glimpse we can
do this this is an association among the
different traits that we scored and so
each of this are a scatter plot of how
the two traits are related to each other
so here's an example of firmness and
bead size usually smaller flower buds
make the head firmer and it is sturdier
and you can see that there's a very
strong positive relationship there is
that if a lot of the firmness is
actually caused by the flower buds being
small so that's what you would expect
not surprising you have some other ones
so plot uniformity is the plant to plant
variation is not at all associated with
firmness you probably wouldn't expect
them to be but so there's you find some
are completely unrelated and then one as
I just implied small beaded ones it's
harder to hide non uniformity and so
you'd expect a strong negative
correlation there that the small beaded
stuff tends to look less uniform and
sure enough that's a negative
relationship but the the way to look at
that is
hey there's some here that have small
beads and look uniform great so breeders
are great at tossing out the junk and
looking at only the good stuff and so
that's what happens here is keep the
good stuff and then in comparing the
material over these many sites you have
to really condense the information so we
ended up using spider plots is one way
to describe it so each of the axes is a
different traits and they're grouped a
little bit so we've got firmness bead
size bead uniformity are the first three
so those are important traits that are
difficult to get the dome is also
important and sensitive to heat a lot of
the time then head uniformity color head
expression how far it comes up plot
uniformity and holding time which you
can see it's sensitive Green is growing
cool conditions red in hot conditions so
green magic is when we started was the
most common variety in the east marathon
was the most common variety in the world
you can see that it goes down to
horrible low numbers when it's warm iron
man was being sold for being tough
that's how it got its name the red line
is a lot smaller than the green line
Castle dome was another standard we
looked at so this was from the second
year breeding trials we've got some that
are fair in the heat sensitive traits
but really do very nicely and everything
else others that have really quite high
numbers in the heat sensitive traits and
are not too bad in the other ones so
look over the different materials and so
skipping several years ahead now so this
is this is the slide that I'm actually
very excited about so how fast is the
breeding progress when you're working
with very complicated traits well if
you're working with
talented readers who know the art of
breeding progress is fast so on our
rating system a3 was generally set at
where the minimum commercial quality is
so if it's a three you can probably sell
it if everything else is okay and for
was considered really good commercial
quality went to five because some of the
traits go beyond that and so here i put
the axis at three because it's the
minimum and the top at four because
that's what we ultimately want to see
each of these bars is the average of a
hundred and twenty data points of it
they're pretty strong as far as
variations so the red lines are the
standards that's the same varieties
every time five different standards that
are averaged together and the green are
the five best lines in our phase one
trial so when we started this was
material that was people had it they
thought it might be good so the best of
those you see that they're a little bit
improved in the uniform bead a little
bit smoother dome the dome stays okay
and they're a little bit greener so
that's what we started with and three
years of breeding later now the uniform
bead is well into the commercial range
the the dome is still well into the
commercial range here on smoothness
we've maintained the dome having given
up on that and they're much greener so
we've had remarkable progress here
so we've had and there's further crosses
being made so the anticipation is that
this will continue up but to be able to
go from barely commercial to really well
towards having everything at commercial
a lot of the time it's tremendous
advance on the breeding end so to do
that as a picture we've gone from this
in August to this in August this one
happens to be one of marks but Griff has
lines that also look like this in the
summertime so that you can sell and that
is what the seed companies are
interested in commercializing the
so the material that we started with
here in the early one that is what has
become released as commercial varieties
and so they've been in the yield trial
so just to show you graphically that how
the yield trials were laid out with the
different production areas on the x-axis
here in the year on the on the year on
the x-axis different locations on the
y-axis but how you try to fit so that
the growth happens when it's warm enough
but it's done and ready to harvest
before it gets either too hot or too
cold depending on which end of the
season you're on so we tried to fit the
different locations you can see we go
from very cold areas to very warm areas
try to cover the whole season and these
yield trials have shown that the new
material is stable and superior in each
in their own locations we've had six
varieties released by the seed companies
in the first four years of the project
and are expecting a couple more to come
out this growing season so the based on
the early stuff so the better the better
stuff is on the way it's in the in their
pipeline but I think that is a great
result just thinking about in your own
research what's the mechanism from
getting it from your lab to industry so
it's for sale in the marketplace there's
an awful lot of steps a lot awful lot of
time so seeing this much progress in in
four years is really remarkable and
that's that
the breeders and seed companies in the
project that have moved it along like
that so then we come to the growers
where are the growers going to be and
how can we fit the new varieties ins
look at how where we can stretch the
season a little bit where should we
encourage new production and one of the
elements are looking at that is to look
at climate data we've got tremendous
resources and climate data so we can
look at some patterns to try to guess
where it might fit well and so I first
do sort of a rough picture here i'm
using salinas where the production is
currently amusing as a proxy the mean
minimum temperature what we actually use
in the model is number of days that the
nighttime temperature exceeds 65 degrees
but that's much harder to draw so just a
mean minimum temperature on actually a
daily basis and so you can see Salinas
is pretty flat so blue here is where
it's really too cold for it to grow red
is where it's too warm for it to grow or
for it to produce nice heads so the
eastern location in Caribou Maine up
there in the north they have similarly
cool middle of summer that's why they
can produce it in the middle of summer
but very different pattern there in the
continental climate if you look at
Geneva you see that we're warmer than
Maine and just touches that red zone in
a tantalising sort of way western New
York is very productive for coal crop
production so a little bit of
improvement and we can probably do a lot
so what about nearby areas so as an
example I'll use fremont ohio it's on
the southern shore of Lake Erie's or so
it's not that different it's just a
little bit further south and so you can
see they pop up into the red
area quite a bit and so it's actually
quite a lot less suitable you have to
make pretty big changes in the
temperature tolerance of broccoli to go
to that area so if we look at the
harvest season Salinas actually harvests
from april through november and then
they move down to the desert if you look
at maine they actually start harvesting
in july and they go until early october
or whenever they get frozen out so you
see that's quite a bit shorter season
I've got up here sort of my guess is
what the harvest season would be if you
look at new york at slope is steep right
that's our problem it's changing fast
and what we know is that there's a lot
of variability in that but that's what
our harvest season can look like and you
see that that fremont ohio is steeper
still and it's not so much that they're
warmer it's that they're steeper that
makes it a problem so their their season
is quite a bit shorter too so that's
going to be a challenge the other issue
we deal with is rainfall so this is this
past June do you remember June so that
that's a deadly amount of water the
roots need to breathe those roots are
not breathing and I'd like to compare
broccoli production to dragster racing
if you miss a shift in dragster racing
you're out of the picture it doesn't
matter and it's the same thing with
broccoli and this is a Miss chipped it
isn't making the transition from newly
transplanted to rapid growth quickly and
then ends up being a big problem and
you'll get to see a little bit how big
so looking at also at the growers how
should they produce broccoli to make it
profitable has to be more profitable
than whatever they're growing now and we
need some hard numbers on that and some
production systems one thing I noted is
that with cabbage which is very similar
to broccoli in many ways we produce
about 50 to 55 tons per acre in New York
and the southeast on much lighter soils
around 30 tons an acre and yet both
locations are producing typically 400 to
450 boxes in acre about half of
California so if you monkeyed around
with the growing a little bit could you
move western New York production a
little bit closer to California than it
is in Georgia and so we tried some
nutrition and particularly plant
population changes so the traditional
population here is similar to other
transplanted vegetable crops maybe
fourteen fifteen sixteen thousand plants
per acre so we're going with some higher
numbers here so here there's the rose or
fifteen inches apart and there's a every
fourth row is skipped and they're either
six eight or twelve inches apart in the
row we know that there are production
systems that will will pack them even as
tight as this 52 thousand population so
this is two weeks after transplanting
what they should look like they're
filling in in the row for the most part
except for the 12 inch 13 weeks you've
got a pretty solid stand here four and a
half weeks this is about when the
herbicide wears off so
now weed management is one of the big
problems so if your herbicide where's
often we'd start terminating at this
point how big a problem with the wheels
going to be they basically don't stand a
chance the root the broccoli roots fill
the entire soil and there's no light
coming to the ground so we'd management
really works out nice if you have this
kind of growth and 52 days is when
harvest begins so on this one you can
see it's a little bit lighter green
because the nitrogen is moving towards
the heads of few little leaves that were
shaded out they're moving the nitrogen
up into the head so doing very high
fertility production but not excessive
fertility nitrogens being used
effectively so what happens in terms of
productivity with these so here's a
graph of the cumulative yields so the
lowest population does exactly what
experience has been with low populations
it starts produced you do three cuts and
you've got a yield here we got about 550
because we're doing high fertility there
so we beat the state average on that one
with the intermediate population there's
about a five day delay in maturity so
giving up something there but there's
more plants that produce heads so you're
putting up the yield close to 700 on
that one when they were packed tighter
then they started competing with each
other so even though they were only
delayed a few more days they start
pooping out and so there's a lot of
plants that don't make anything
harvestable at all so they were too
tight so we found that moving up into
the 30s 30,000 something is going to be
a lot better than 15,000 which is where
people generally are no found with
quality so I used a hollow this is
hollow stem here a hollow stem
susceptible varieties
in this trial it's a delicious tasting
one so it's popular for that and it's
basically how thick the stem is
determines whether the pith is going to
open up and so if you look at the head
weight these are all 5-inch heads so the
heavier heads are the ones that have
thicker stems that's the dimension
that's changing and at the low
population we're getting big thick stems
with lots of hollow stem at the highest
population we're getting under sized
heads and want to try to keep them close
to point two kilos so the intermediate
population not only gave the highest
yield it gave the highest quality so
this tells us what the optimal
population should look like and so
growers can find what their own is but I
said we're doing this seat when you make
money so let's do the numbers on that so
2013 was an excellent year for growing
broccoli it did very well the green
curve is the revenue the red curve is
the total cost and we're figuring
everything owning the tractors the barns
interest payments all of that stuff so
it's not marginal cost its total cost
by way of comparison good corn crop is
worth 600 700 dollars way down there so
this is very big money compared with
even some profitable crops so the low
population made pretty good money
intermediate population make even more
money 2014 was a challenging year we had
a hail storm come through just before
heading another mischief if you will
where the plants really were shocked
they stopped growing for several days is
from the physical shock of the hailstorm
so we had lower yields then but if you
look at those differences where the
profit is that intermediate population
still made good money going with a lower
population just barely broke even and
even that one is higher than the
industry standard so moving those
populations up is going to make broccoli
a lot more economically attractive so a
2015 I showed you a 2015 looks like it
was a terrible terrible year so what
happens when you have a terrible year
with that huge investment the costs are
still high and at the lower population
it's still pulled it out that turned out
to be all bunching broccoli instead of
crown broccoli so the highest population
lost money but the grower still doesn't
lose a ton of money even when there's a
really disastrous event so sometimes you
don't you don't make much money but at
least you know and you have six thousand
dollars an acre at risk there so coming
out even with that one is actually
pretty good news in a terrible year so
to continue down the line of the
economic analysis for making that money
here's the price per box over the last
five years at Eastern terminal markets
so that prices vary all over the place
depending on
now you're who you're selling it to but
the terminal market price at least is
basically the same thing all the time so
you know what's going on there and
they're reported every week so you can
get the numbers on them looked at the
blue line is a bunch and the green line
is a crown the market is more and more
crown cut there's a few holdouts that
are still doing bunches the southeast
which is very conservative in their food
tastes New York City which apparently is
very conservative in its food tastings
you want to draw that inference and
organic tends to go with a bunch but the
bulk of the market these days is crown
you can see that there used to be a
differential between the two but for the
last few years that's pretty much gone
the price jumps around a lot from year
to year so if you're a grower going into
a spot market like this it can be very
hard to budget and so it's really
important to make sure that at fourteen
fifteen dollars you're making money and
sometimes you make a lot of money but
you don't know when that's going to
happen some years there's a transition
right around New Year's it often comes
as they're switching over production
from Salinas to the desert and sometimes
there's a big extra supply coming out of
Mexico right around then that they're
trying to catch that so we looked at the
total production costs for the east to
see how they compare with California and
we looked at some models and the the
numbers came in remarkably similar
they're all like eleven dollars I put
several dollars of error bars on each of
these because it depends so much locally
but these numbers are definitely
competitive but what goes into those
varies a great deal that the cost
structures of California water costs a
lot here water comes down free or
sometimes too much but it comes down
free land is very expensive in
California land is not very expensive
here labor is much more difficult to get
here so there's there's significant
differences one of the big variables so
yeah so I'll remind your son that price
chart $15 production costs 11 so that's
kind of where your potential profit
margin is when the big variables is the
post-harvest costs so broccoli is all
really rapidly growing tissue right it's
respiring like crazy and so if you take
a bunch of broccoli that's out in the
sunshine and you put in a box you put a
bunch of boxes together they're all busy
respiring a very high temperature what's
going to happen hot they're going to
turn yellow they're going to burn up all
their sugar they're going to be awful so
it has to get cold really quickly and
there's been a lot of work done on this
and cold means 32 degrees Fahrenheit it
doesn't mean 38 degrees 38 degrees rapid
rapid enough respiration to cost a lot
of quality from the farm to the buyer so
dinner yet cold is critical so there's a
number of different technologies and it
depends on the scale that the growers
working at so one of the most common is
hydro cooling room basically dip it into
ice-cold water so this is a conveyor
belt that takes the Box takes it down
into the ice cold water pump it comes
again really very simple straightforward
not very expensive you have to have
access to gigantic blocks of ice at a
low cost but if you've got that that's
pretty good
one that lasts a lot longer is this
liquid ice injection so here the boxes
are open there's a dispenser and it
dispenses a bunch of chipped ice on top
that works great on a small scale but
doing those boxes one at a time is high
labor one that we've seen that doesn't
cool very much is just using the tap
water or well water that's whatever the
temperature of your groundwater is
that'll take a lot of the field heat out
so if you are delivering on the same day
it'll be cold enough as long as it gets
sold within a day you can get away with
it that's really cheap if you have that
water available then cooling with solid
ice this is absolutely the cheapest one
when everybody starts with because all
it takes is one of those plastic shovels
and a box full of ice from the ice
company and you shovel the ice into the
box one by one very labor-intensive it
costs a fortune per box so for people
starting out they use that one but the
incentive to switch something else it is
quick what they use in California a huge
scale it is actually not super cheap but
they have to do this to get it across
the country and that is they inject an
ice water slurry into an entire pallet
of boxes and so the water ice mixture
goes in there it gets into every nook
and cranny and the water comes out
so finally I mentioned that it's hard to
get market access for growers here and
it's hard for the markets to access the
growers and these are a bunch of the
problems that people have run into and
we have a program going on in New York
and a few other states in the east that
is under the heading of food hub and
these are aggregation sites where
there's a manager who will work with a
number of different farms and
consolidate shipments work with buyers
who are used to calling up Salinas and
saying hey I need two truckloads of this
Annette that they'll be able to speak
the same language as the buyers and be
able to negotiate fairly among the
growers to meet you know it looks the
way it should look comes in the amount
you promised it allows them to use
cooling technology more efficiently and
so developing these food hubs is
something that's moving along we're
having a great time working with the
really the extension system is where the
strength is in this one so the question
now is
and broccoli via school is kale so so
that's that's the last slide so I've
told you a little bit about the breeding
in the physiology and how we're taking
that and how do you bring it to market
so that the seed companies have an
incentive to market to the eastern
growers so that we can have a good base
of eastern growers all the way from
immokalee to the Saint John River Valley
in the north with in particular a nice
big group in western New York where
there's huge potential for tens of
millions of dollars of production in the
next few years thanks very much
heavy Club
there are non heading broccoli varieties
but the labor costs and so
No
the Phenom heading types that received
much less reading code that quality
consistency of Florida productivity
lower
how unfortunate apartments great for
market gardens of all of those traits
they believe to be the most important if
the domain
that is the one that
the dough means get his take out this
right do you know any genes that control
of domain based on work Kings grasp it
and so does so the flattening of the
dome is when that outer branches the
oldest branches start to grow first as
it's getting ready to bolt it's getting
closer to a fan thesis those will start
to grow timing of that stem elongation
relative to the maturity of the head at
that time is shipped so that's that's
what
I jumped on the cheese follow that for
sure that that's that that's the timing
event that's different yes genetically
complex trade
have your question but are you working
with any power hours or any child
uh it doesn't seem like thats going to
pay off for most markets because we can
move up and down the coast that the cost
of producing broccoli in the hoop house
is so much higher than shipping it
which is the distance that the hoophouse
clear benefit so they're not getting
types is actually some work on the
Atlantic seaboard for joining houses put
some of the non head unless they can
actually over winter
work on for a CSA a restaurant and half
those in carrier to sprint Prairie
that's
we have we have a question from
thomas what under full of the project in
its place so the major goals in the next
case of the projects are the easy answer
because keep our clothes on top so we
want to understand the genetics of the
complex traits better because to improve
them further we're going to have to use
molecular markers to identify the
combinations because we're not going to
get enough difference between a single
one one level of genetic tolerance from
a high level is that stacking because
they're not seeing about gene trade zone
and careful about my terminology here
but put more layers of that on we need
to be using molecular markers to see
what we're combining different sources
of resistance of developing the food
hubs is actually a significant part of
it because we need to make that volume
grow and getting that the new growers
who might be ends to a hundred acres of
broccoli that kind of scale for their
factory as part of their vegetable mix
they're going to need the distribution
channels and getting that regional
trialing system expanded to include a
lot more seed companies so there's more
contribution to the overall improvement
of variety so that those are the areas
that were looking primarily for
thomas in terms of carbon footprint yeah
might it not be argued that trucking
broccoli from immokalee to New York or
Boston it's as carbon intensive as
flying in from
12 all on his client but trucking is
that trucking if you're going yeah
immokalee to Boston mark versus
silliness to Boston boston-based out
it's not a huge difference because
they're both a
and my advice going from
mercer county named through atlanta
ergon from blanco in Mexico to Atlanta
that's not very you know so you do hit a
short break even point there and that's
where Miguel Gomez is work has been
modeling that as far as for each of the
different major markets in the east how
much should be supplied from east coast
but a distance for it make sense don't
try to invest in something that really
doesn't have much potential not that
much local
cheers though is a spring or fall a
better market where is it
the way better in the fall spring is
really challenging because it wants to
grow and it's more vegetatively and once
the head when it's cold and that's the
exact opposite of what happens the
spring is riveted that's our most
difficult season to find that
I want to thank Thomas capacity this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu